And then let's quickly go over the scene setup for the demo today so that you can get a rough
representation of what we're working with today. So we want to display the vehicle blueprint,
which is an actor here, and the actor will take in data from the UI. We'll use the data to update
the 3d model in some way. And also we can also hold a 3d widget component. So if you see this
components box at the top left hand side here, you can see an add button, you can actually add
widgets to this blueprint, which is really powerful functionality. Here's the vehicle blueprint
component. And then also we have our scene setup. So we just have this blank level, we've got a
camera actor. And if you go into the camera actor properties, you want to make sure auto activate
for player is player zero. And this means that we can possess this camera like we were talking
about before with our controller, we can take input when we actually want to play this experience.
We have a rec light setup, you can use a point light as well. They're both set to stationary.
We want the vehicle in there. And then we've just created a cube, which is the mesh floor,
and just stretched out there. So that's the basic scene setup that we'll be working with today.